foreign
[Music]
Ty and access management focuses on the
who of your Cloud organization it lets
an administrator authorize who can take
actions on specific resources based on
permissions and roles as the next line
of defense organization policy lets
administrators Define the what I.E what
resource configurations are allowed in
their organization independent of who or
where the request comes from
it ensures compliance and conformance at
a higher level than IAM by ensuring that
only secure and compliant resources are
used across the organization
the organization policy service gives
you centralized and programmatic control
over your organization's Cloud resources
as the organization policy administrator
you will be able to configure security
guard rails across your entire resource
hierarchy you can think about
organization policy within Google Cloud
as its One-Stop governance guardrail
system security admins can use it to
enforce what types of resource
configurations are allowed in their
environment
this ensures your company stays within
compliance boundaries and adheres to
your company's security policies
org policies can improve security at the
scale needed by today's Cloud users this
is particularly important as you scale
your org across thousands of projects
resources and users and you don't want
to slow down development due to
compliance or security requirements
for example you can centralize control
of gcp resource configurations to meet
governance and security goals
find and establish guardrails for your
development teams to stay within
compliance boundaries
and help project owners and their teams
move quickly without worry of breaking
compliance
organization policies are made up of
guard rails or constraints that allow
you to set yourself up well for security
and compliance
think of the constraints as an intent or
rule set that defines what behaviors are
controlled this rule set is then applied
to a resource hierarchy node as an
organization policy which implements the
rules defined in the constraint
for instance
you can limit resource sharing based on
domain
limit the usage of identity and access
management service accounts and restrict
the physical location of newly created
resources
there are many more constraints that
give you fine-grained control of your
organization's resources for more
information see the list of all
organization policy service constraints
Linked In the description below in
addition to the list of pre-configured
constraints that gcp offers security
admins can also Define custom
constraints using common expression
language Cel to create and manage
resource restrictions tailored to their
specific use cases
for more information see the links in
the description below
when a Google Cloud resource Acts or is
in a state that is counter to an
organization policy applicable to that
resource it is in violation
organization policy service will enforce
constraints and block resource actions
such as create or update resource that
would result in these violations when
resource actions conflict with enforced
organization policies such actions will
not be allowed and will generate
auditable logs for further analysis and
Reporting you can review these logs
findings and plan for remediation
letting you have business continuity
while hardening your services
to set up your Cloud organization's
guardrails to improve security and
compliance on your systems you can start
using the organization policy service
today you can find out more details
using our overview page linked in the
description below thanks for watching
[Music]